What can one party to a contract do when they learned that the other is planning
to breach the contract.
The next case Hotchner versus de la tour deals with exactly such a situation.
Edgar de la tour planned a three month grand tour of the European continent for
the summer of 1852 he decided to hire a courier to accompany him on his travels
and so in April he hired Albert Hotchner to serve as his career on the trip,
which was to begin on June 1st but de la tour soon changed his mind.
On May 11th he wrote that he no longer required Hotchner services and that
hoster would receive no compensation.
On May 22nd Hotchner sued de la tour for breach of contract and then sometime
between then and June 1st he managed to find another job.
I'm just as good terms but not beginning until July 4th this case comes from
England and we are reading the decision from the court of Queen's bench on
appeal.
After Hotchner won at trial,
there were two legal questions for the appeals court to answer.
The first was whether Hotchner was obligated even after receiving de la tour,
his letter to be ready to company him on a three month tour of Europe beginning
on June 1st note that this would have prevented him from accepting the
alternative employment beginning on July 4th the second question was whether
hoster could sue de la before June 1st given that de Latour had not yet failed
to meet any of his contractual obligations on both of these questions.
Chief Justice Lord Campbell ruled for Hotchner.
The court answers these questions together with two main arguments,
a doctrinal argument and an economic argument.
Lord Campbell finds no universal rule that whereby agreement and act as to be
done on a future day.
No action can be brought for a breach of the agreement till the day for doing
the act as arrived.
He runs through a number of examples where courts have allowed such suits,
contracts of marriage,
where one party marry someone else in contracts to lease a particular property
where the less or leases it to someone else for the same time period and in
contracts for purchase of goods where the seller sells them to someone else.
In this case,
he suggests that if de la tour had set sail for Australia before June 1st
arrived,
Hotchner could have sued for breach under the same precedence.
The court finds that when parties enter into these sorts of contracts,
quote,
there is the relation constituted between the parties in the meantime by the
contract and that they impliedly promise that in the meantime,
neither will do anything to the prejudice of the other inconsistent with that
relation.
When someone marries someone other than his or her fiance or as in this case,
a party renounces a commitment that person has breached quote an implied
contract if either of them renounces the engagement unquote.
What this means is that de Latour has already breached the contract when he
sends the letter to decline or services,
and so hotjar is freed from his obligation obligations and free to sue these
two.
These two forms of repudiation are still recognized in contract law.
Section two 50 of the second restatement describes two methods by which a party
can repudiate a contract.
The first is subsection a it.
It's a explicit repudiation of the sort de la tour gave to hoster,
not just any statement counts as a repudiation.
Though courts have made clear that there must be a definite and final
communication of the intention to forego performance before the anticipated
breach may be the subject of legal action.
The second type of repudiation is in subsection B and it includes actions that
are inconsistent with the promise or his ability to complete his or her PR
promise.
The past precedents sided by Lord Campbell fall into this category.
A fiance who marries someone else has rendered herself quote,
apparently unable to perform quote.
The general rule from this case is also been incorporated into scattered
sections of the a UCC dealing with repudiation,
including repudiation by conduct.
Lord Campbell also makes an argument based on considerations of economics and
public policy for why hoster should be free to find a new client by allowing him
to do so quote,
instead of remaining idle and laying out money and preparations,
which must be useless,
he is at liberty to seek services under another employer,
unquote.
This arrangement.